okay so we already covered the facts of
Donald Trump's impeachment impeached on
two articles article one and article two
passing by two hundred with 230 and 229
votes in the house respectively last
night now there have been predictions
for a while that getting impeached would
transform Donald Trump into the most
erratic version of himself and those
predictions have come true he was in
rare form yesterday tweeting all day the
White House said he was gonna have a
busy day working he tweeted all day
dozens and dozens of tweets endlessly
some misspelled many with random
capitalization of words in the middle of
sentences all riddled with erratic
unhinged lies it was not a good day for
Donald Trump by the time he showed up at
a rally last night in Michigan I don't
have video today but check it out rather
than we have ever seen him falling apart
coming unglued seeming to have those
problems Jerusalem and all that stuff a
really very strange rally last night
Trump tweeting to kick things off
yesterday morning can you believe that I
will be impeached today by the radical
left do-nothing Democrats and I did
nothing wrong
a terrible thing read the transcripts
this soild never happened to another
president again say a prayer
Trump soiled himself on that tweet and
ultimately deleted it and correctly
spelled should Trump continuing to tweet
all day furiously retweeting right-wing
agitant propaganda disinformation as
well as his completely misguided
understandings of even what was going on
I was thinking Trump obviously is
furious and he of course doesn't like
what's going on but he doesn't
understand a lot of things he's probably
sitting around even confused as he
watched his hearings in the debate about
what's going on
but remember impeachment is not a normal
thing only three presidents including
Trump have been impeached Donald Trump's
behavior is not the behavior of an
innocent person
Trump continuing later tweeting a wacked
out all capital letters tweets saying
quote such atrocious lies by the radical
left do-nothing Democrats this is an
assault on America and an assault on the
Republican Party now the this is so
funny the upside of Trump tweeting in
all caps is that it prevents him from
erroneously capitalizing words randomly
just the first letter as he typically
does in his tweets you solved that
problem by going all caps it
unfortunately makes you look even more
erratic and unhinged and then Donald
Trump giving his take on what will
happen which seems to contain a possible
triple negative this is Trump attempting
to quote a guy named Andy McCarthy of
course from Fox News
can anybody parse the grammar here Trump
says in the end here nothing happened
we don't approach anything like the
egregious conduct that should be
necessary before a president should be
removed from office I believe that a
president can't be removed from office
if there is no reasonable possibility
that the Senate won't convict and remove
the president can't be removed if there
is no reasonable possibility of the
Senate not convicting maybe my English
is my second language I admit but
something seems a little wacky with
those negations this probably gives you
a sense of what was going on yesterday
an erratic unhinged and maybe even
scared individual this is a historic
presidency we've seen everything from
Donald Trump pushing world leaders out
of the way to be up front
during the photo-op to seeing Donald
Trump hand draw with a sharpie a more
politically convenient weather map for a
hurricane and all sorts of corruption
cronyism and bribery in between I do
have to agree with Donald Trump in one
sense this never should have happened in
the sense that it shouldn't have been
possible for this to happen in the sense
that Trump never should have been
president to begin with but that ship
has long sailed this is where we are
innocent people don't go crazy like this
he's going crazy this is the meme of old
man yells at cloud personified on
Twitter every single day and once again
I I'm not being negative or positive I'm
just being realistic he will probably
get away with it when the Senate acquits
and then it will be up to you
and me and particularly voters in those
key states that made a difference in
2016 to decide because it's really a
decision if we go out to vote half the
country doesn't normally vote if we go
out to vote we get to decide it is not
going to be allowed to continue for
another four years we'll have more about
this on the shows Instagram page david
david pakman show is the show Instagram
follow us there and while you were there
follow me at david pakman